so yeah my name is Stratus and this
morning I'm gonna be talking you to you
about conversational interfaces so a
little bit about me before I begin as
you know I'm a senior user experience
designer at a paper scheduled garage and
for those of you who don't know what a
vive is it's probably the coolest
insurance company you can find through
our campuses all over the world
including the UK France Canada and
Singapore we're trying to help our
millions of customers make better
financial decisions through customer
centered design and through new
technology and one of the ways we've
been experimenting with to help our
customers manage or solve their problems
is conversational interfaces and I'm
sure you've heard about conversational
interfaces but I'm also sure that you
heard about a lot of other jargon than
is often used interchangeably so before
I start talking about projects that are
using those interfaces I think it's it
will be worth clarifying the lingo so a
conversational interface as an interface
that emulates human to human interaction
the abbreviation is Kui and the main the
difference between more traditional
graphical user interfaces in which you
navigate through visual metaphors like
folders files you click on buttons is
that in a conversational interface you
just tell this the service what you
would like it to do through language and
then it does it for you so there are two
main types the the first one is voice
first assistance like Google home and
Amazon Alexa and text first assistance
you where you can find websites or on
platforms like Facebook Messenger and
slack and one other thing that I need to
clarify is that AI is advanced
algorithms that can greatly enhance a
service that uses a conversational
interface but on the same time it's not
synonymous with it it can also power
traditional web pages a good example of
this is my Aviva a platform that we have
at Aviva that allows our customers to
have all their policies into one place
that learns about the preferences and
unique situations and provides them with
personalized offers so AI is not
necessary for us
that uses a conversational interface so
now we clarified that let's talk about
what we do at Aviva so in a video we're
experimenting with both services that
uses voice and text-based conversational
interfaces we have our customer support
bot powered by news that helps our
customers get help and answers to
questions that might have like when they
want to make a claim or they want to
make a change their policy by allow them
to type express their intention through
a natural language we also have a skill
for Amazon Alexa which allows customers
to get explanations to confusing
insurance terms by just asking through
their voice and for one of our brands
called me happy calm we have a facebook
messenger bot that helps them get a home
insurance quote in a conversational way
and as you can see we're experimenting a
lot with those interfaces but it's only
us the industry has seen a big rise in
the past few years it was projected that
in 2017 people would use assistive BOTS
or Siri more than once a month that
almost half US consumers are using voice
and label BOTS and big tech giants are
integrating services with conversational
interfaces into the core strategies so
that has led to the discussion on
whether we eventually going to use
language and conversational interfaces
for everything and after working in
products that are using them for the
past few years my my thinking of that is
that they're not and while they have
many experience benefits they have also
very experienced limitations offer
graphical interface so during my talk
I'm going to draw up examples from our
work on what we found that works one of
the benefits of using a conversational
approach what are the limitations and
how we think that they can be improved
in the future so let's start with
experience benefits the first one is
that when the end result can be
articulated easily then a service that
uses a conversational interface can do
skip and do a lot of the intermediate
steps for you and save you time for
example at a company like Aviva which
has a lot of products and a lot of
flex products if somebody would like to
contact us they would have to go to the
contact us page select the carry motor
category then find motorcycle insurance
then find claims and because we have
different types of claims they would
have to find the number for new claims
it's worth noting we have more than
15,000 different numbers out of either
while if they use their chat boat they
would just articulate there and go and
the bots will just skip all those steps
for them and provide them with the
information they need to meet their
goals faster so speed is one thing the
other thing is mostly about voice
interfaces is convenience so voice
interfaces allow people to do services
when they have their hands full and they
allow them to multitask or when they
don't have other devices around an
example is still we have for Amazon
Alexa which allows our customers
wouldn't say they're reading an
insurance document that they have an
unknown jargon to ask Alexa via voice
without having to pick up their phone
open their browser and search for their
question so it can be more convenient in
certain points the last thing is that
they feel more personal and we've seen
that we as I said before for one of our
brands we have a Facebook Messenger but
that helps customers get a home
insurance quote so we tested that versus
the experience of the website and even
though both experience had to say
questions and then though our messenger
bought didn't really have a I didn't
learn about the customers preferences
and needs to create a really
personalized experience people still
felt our users that most of our users
that it felt more personal even though
they couldn't articulate why many times
so it feels more personal when the end
result can be articulated quickly it's
faster and voice and conversational
interfaces can provide convenience so
now let's talk about experience
limitations we have identified two types
the first ones are have to do with
technology which means that a temporary
because technology always evolves and
conversation and there are some
conversational limitations which just
they are inherent to the nature of
language and words so the technological
ones
that conversational agents of the moment
don't really understand meaning most of
them at least and they like a lot of
understanding that humans have when they
converse so when we talk with other
people we have context we have empathy
we have common sense we have shared
experiences but at the moment most bots
use the most popular AI - it's called
natural language understanding we just
extracts certain phrases or certain key
words and map them to decision trees so
that means that designers need to cater
for all the different nuances of
language and map different words or
phrases to different decision trees
which many times leads to disappointment
because you cannot really cater for
everything and you can lead to examples
like a few days ago was using about the
kid diagnosed what I had cuz I wasn't
feeling very well so I logged in through
Facebook and they knew some of my
information
I said I'm sick and it concluded that
I'm asking about pregnancy so obviously
that likely wouldn't happen when you
converse to a human and now we have
conversational limitations some things
in conversations the affordances and
constraints are not very easily
discoverable and also certain types of
information cannot be easily conveyed
through words let's take for example
this pet insurance we have that uses a
graphical user interface here all the
constraints are visible up front you
know you can get a quote find out more
about cover options and found out how
you can get help and the likelihood of
error is very little because the
experience is constrained in a way that
prevents it but in a conversational
interface especially when there is free
entry input there is no really no
constraints of how far you can push the
conversation how much you can mask and
very often that can lead to errors
because users have high expectations and
they will try to ask and push the system
as much as I can and the other thing is
that you need to rely on Rico because
you need to remember what you're allowed
to ask which usually doesn't lead to a
great experience in terms of usability a
great example is our called me happy
messenger board so even though we try to
set the right expectations throughout
in general journey that it's just for
home insurance quotes more than 50% of
demands were about getting customer
support and you know that partly
illustrates that we were trying to solve
the wrong problem for our users but it
also illustrates that the experience
didn't prevent them and didn't make the
affordances clear and the other thing is
that just some type of information is
very hard to be conveyed through
language and words both in terms of the
user conveying into the system and from
the system conveying it to the user this
you saved my future a tool that helps
customers visualize their ideal
retirement lifestyle and by answering a
few questions they can at the end toggle
between different retirement lifestyles
depending of how much they would like to
spend on things like travel like food
home and see how's that affect whether
their retirement lifestyle and their
income get immediate feedback on how it
affects their cost and income so that in
a conversational experience would be
really hard to convey through words and
also even articulating that you want to
pick one option over the other say the
third one or pick the one for with
ninety nine pounds for spending on a
home retirement lifestyle will require
more cognitive effort than graphical
user interface and that becomes even
more prominent in more advanced
financial tools like our pension tool
which the user can see how their pension
can perform in the future by changing
the contributions or how their funds are
invested which uses more than a thousand
data points to convey very abstract
information which would not be easy to
convey through words so the key takeaway
from this is don't try to solve every
problem with conversational interfaces
so now that we know that they're both
benefits and shortcomings on those types
of interfaces how can we make them
better to find out how can we commit and
better I think it's good to look about
how we started interacting with
computers so since the very beginning
we were always fascinating about what
computers could do and as Alan Cooper
said puts it nicely the biggest problem
was that it was hard for us to tell them
what we would like them to do so a lot
of people would argue that language is
the way to go
and words because it's very natural to
us that we've been using it for more
than a hundred thousand years and
because of that that's why we started
with a command line which is in a way
it's a form of a conversational
interface and when that didn't get much
adoption because of the fact that they
required memorized syntax we've been
dreaming about bringing it back for a
long time the counter-argument to that
is that also graphical interfaces in
visual metaphors of direct manipulation
like folders and buttons and windows are
also natural to us because we use the
recommend emulation and everyday lives
as well and we've been working on those
types of interfaces to meet our customer
needs and solve problems for many years
we've been improving them and they're
good for certain things as we've seen so
since we know the conversational
experience have the following benefits
they're faster when the end state can be
articulated easily they allow free hands
interactions so you make them more
convenient at some points and they feel
more personal and human and we know the
graphical interfaces are faster for
tasks the require exploratory
interactions and fiddling and can convey
informations that can be abstract and
they cannot be easily hundred through
language and have easily discoverable
affordances and constraints so why don't
we could combine them to create
something better and allows us to solve
our customers problems in more efficient
ways and this has already started
happening we say this app operator it
uses a conversational interface which is
personal it feels personal but it makes
the constraints more visible by using a
graphical representation for example you
have only three options price objects to
choose from so the likelihood of error
gets minimized and you don't have to
rely on recall to remember what you're
allowed to ask and we can learn from
other markets as well which at the most
popular chat up in Asia almost 1 billion
users uses a conversational interface
but very often users interact with mini
apps within it for tasks that are more
appropriate and that has led Facebook
create a thing called webview which
allows you to create our web pages
within the conversational chat board
environment which we use that called me
happy to come for the question of what's
your address because Allah aligned
to select between a list would minimize
the likelihood of error so that can be
enhanced even further by using elements
from multiple modalities so at some
point we could lead to an experience
like this you know play your short clip
for the Ironman movie just to illustrate
my point so I stole this on the stock
industry central database should another
to trust right now till further notice
why don't we just keep everything in my
private server working on a secret
project are we sir
[Music]
I don't want this flaring up in the
wrong hands so as you can see here Tony
Stark used conversation when it made
more sense when you could articulate the
end result save the files to the server
that allow him to multitask but when he
wanted to explore this hologram and see
different aspects of it at different
sides of it he used gestures and direct
manipulation which would be we will
require more cognitive effort to
articulate through language and part of
we partly are doing this at the moment
with amazon firetv for example you can
use your voice because it's easier than
typing to search for certain types of
films and then you can use your remote
control to quickly scan between
graphical elements to see which movie
would be interesting to you and
obviously with more advanced stuff
coming up soon with Microsoft Cortana
and hololens so at the end of the day
this is how we navigate the physical
world around this for example at a
restaurant you're gonna use your direct
manipulation to scan quickly elements on
the menu and find out what is the thing
you would like to choose and then if you
have further questions or your more
personal connection you would talk to
the waiter in a conversational way of
course so two key takeaways
conversational interfaces have various
usability limitations and they're not an
appropriate tool to solve every problem
- and then we can minimize those to
usability limitations by incorporating
interactions from graphical user
interface and multiple modalities thank
you
you